in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for July 27, on which we commemorate our Holy Father
Clement of Okrid, 1st Bishop of Bulgaria, and the disciples of Saints Cyril and Methodias,
Ghoraz, Nahum, Angelarius and Sabas.
Our Holy Father Clement was probably of Slav origin, and was born in about the year 840.
Becoming very early a disciple of Saint Methodos, he strove throughout his life to imitate
his spiritual Father in all things, and received from him and his brother Saint Constantine,
a love of the Holy Scriptures, and an ardent desire to take the good news to the barbarian
peoples in their own language.
From the death of Methodos, the apostle of the Slavs in the year 885, his sworn enemy,
Bishop Wicking, set upon his disciples.
As it was through their teaching that Methodos and Orthodoxy had continued to spread among
the people, and had encouraged them to turn away from frankish influence.
He denounced them to Svetloplok, accusing them of conspiracy, produced before the prince,
Clement and Ghoraz explained that they were not seeking to rebel against his authority,
but to defend the Orthodox dogma of the Holy Trinity in battling against the Filioque.
The depraved prince, remaining insensitive to theological argument, handed the Holy
missionaries over to the Germans, who dragged some of them through thorns and sold others
into slavery.
The leaders of the Byzantine mission, Ghoraz's Clement Nahum, Lawrence, Savas and Angelarius
were chained in prison, with a formal ban on their communicating with their fellow workers,
comforted however by the Lord and confirmed in their resolve by prayer.
They were freed from their bonds at the moment when an earthquake shook the area.
Instead of recognizing a sign from God in this, Svetloplok had them loaded with heavier chains
and subjected to even cooler treatment.
After three days, an identical miracle was wrought, but the Calus tyrant had the saints punished
the more severely, leaving them in their cell, covered in wounds and without food.
A detachment of harsh and uncouth soldiers then dragged them out of prison to drive them
from the kingdom of Moravia.
Clement Nahum, Angelarius and Savas, traveled towards the Danube in the hope of reaching Bulgaria.
Having in a village, they were welcomed by a noble man, but they had scarcely arrived
when the man's son died.
The saints prayed to the Lord, and the child immediately got up, as once had Lazarus,
the friend of Christ.
Having crossed the Danube, they arrived in Belgrade, where the governor, having learned
who they were, had them taken without delay to the court of Tsar Boris, who had at the
time a great desire to receive such men of God.
The Holy Prince showed them the greatest marks of honor, and thanking God for having allowed
the arrival in his country of confessors of the faith, like to the apostles in all things.
He asked them to give him a detailed account of all their tribulations.
During their stay at court, the saints were often summoned by the Tsar to instruct him in
the dogma of the church, the lives of the saints, and what is expected of a Christian prince.
After some time, he confided to Clement, the evangelizing of the region of Kutmitzavitsa,
Okrid, and Galavinitsa, in the year 885.
With the support of local authorities, the saint was able quickly to scatter the evangelical
seed, and he brought together about three and a half thousand disciples.
Together with the good news, he also taught them the alphabet, discovered by Saint Cyril,
which he himself had modified, and into which Saint Clement translated many works from
Byzantium, so that the new church could be built on the solid foundations of apostolic tradition.
He had more than 300 of his disciples ordained, and had them live in their parishes in order
to deepen the missionary work and the patient labor in the uprooting of pagan customs and
superstition.
On Boris's death, his son Simeon, in the years 893 through 927, took the succession
and showed the same zeal for the evangelization of his people.
He held Saint Clement in great esteem, looking on him as his spiritual father, and had him
consecrated Bishop of Velitsa, or Drembitsa, with jurisdiction over Western Macedonia.
The first hierarchy of Slav birth, Saint Clement showed himself a worthy successor to the
apostles, and redoubled his efforts in preaching and the instruction of the people, a work that
he considered more important than daily bread.
In his free time, he continued the translation work, begun by Saint Cyril and Methodius,
and spent his nights in prayer.
To make up for the lack of preachers, he wrote a series of sermons in Slavonic, for the
principal feasts of the year, which the priests could read to the people, and thus nourished
them with the doctrine of the Holy Fathers.
He also translated and composed offices for the feasts of the saints, and gave great
attention to the worthy celebration of the offices of the church, which contributed more
than anything else to the conversion and instruction of the people.
He founded a monastery in Okrid, dedicated to Saint Pantelemon, and a church to which he loved
to withdraw.
One day, when he had arrived in the city on a pastoral visit, two blind paralytics fell
at his feet to ask his help.
After having made sure that there was no one else present, the saint raised his eyes to
heaven, and the two cripples got to their feet healed.
After twenty years of apostolic work, Saint Clement, by then very old, asked Zarr Simeon
to let him retire and devote his last days to prayer in his monastery in Okrid.
The Zarr, in surprise, swore that he would allow no other than Clement on the arch-apiscopal
throne, and that he would rather abdicate than allow the saint to retire.
Saint Clement had to submit, and promised to speak no more of resigning.
But as soon as he returned to his monastery, he fell ill.
After a vision of Saint Cyril and Methodius, who told him of his coming death, he set his
affairs in order, wrote his testament, and gave his soul into the Lord's hands in peace,
on the 27th of July, in the year 916.
He was quickly venerated as the apostle of the Bulgarians, who owed him not only his evangelization
and first organization of the church, but also the foundations of a civilization that they
were soon to pass on to Russia and other Slav peoples.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on
us and save us.